a given Basin has been divided into two
sections what is most nearly the total
length or longest path of the Basin in
feet
Givens area 1's time of concentration is
5 minutes it is short grass with a slope
of 0.02 ft per feet area 2 time of
concentration is 8.5 minutes it is paved
with a slope of 0.01 ft per feet and
area 1 drains to area 2
so we're being asked in this problem to
find the total length of the Basin and
we know that area one drains into area
2 so to find that length we're going to
need to use our time of
concentration and the velocity of each
area but why would I know to use the
velocity and how would I find the
velocity
so you will notice that this problem
provides the slope and Basin
characteristics of each
area there exists a graph on page
396 that can be used to find velocity
using the other information
provided as a quick side note I realize
that having to use this graph is not
obvious if it's actually needed on the
exam there's a chance that it the pro
the problem itself will call out this
graph or provide it to you but just in
case it doesn't it's good to know that
exists in the reference manual and it's
good to know how to use it so that's the
point of this problem so let's get
started so if we start with this
graph you will see if you look on page
396 of the manual that if we Trace over
from the slope
of
0.02 all the way to Short
Grass this will give us a velocity if we
Trace down
of
1T per
second likewise for area two if we Trace
over from
0.01 feet per
foot to the paved section the paved
line that will give us just
about 2 ft per
[Music]
second so all we have to do once we
found the
area so once we found the velocity for
each area all we have to do is multiply
each area's velocity by its respective
time of
concentration so if we have
A1 5
Min
time 60
seconds per
minute
times 1 foot per
second this will give
us 300
ft since we're going to have minutes
cancel out and seconds cancel
out for area
two we have 8.5
minutes times 60 seconds per
minute
[Music]
times
2 feet per
second and this is going to give us
1,20
ft since A1 drains into
A2 we're going to sum these
together
and get 1320 ft as our total length
closest answer over here is the fourth
one and that's all it takes to solve
this
problem again the most important part of
this is knowing that you have to use the
graph so this part is the most important
just take a quick look at it and get
familiar so that you know it exists if
you come across a similar problem on the
exam and that's
it